Let's review a little bit of
what Napoleon was up to going
into the war of the Third
Coalition, which really does
establish Napoleon as the
dominant figure in Europe.
So in 1799, he takes power.
First with two other consuls,
but then he declares himself
First Consul.
So he takes power.
He becomes First-- let me put
that in capital letters--
First Consul.
Then in 1802, actually
before I get to 1802.
Let me say what he
did in 1800.
Remember when he took power,
we were still in the war of
the Second Coalition.
We talked about that
a little bit.
France had lost ground, they
had lost a lot of what they
had gained in the First
Coalition in Italy.
The Austrians had
taken it back.
So Napoleon decides to take
charge, cross the Alps.
This is a picture of Napoleon
crossing the Alps.
Leading the troops into the Alps
to take back what he felt
needed to be taken back
from Austria.
And then we learned in the
last video that that
essentially is what ended
the First Coalition.
So in 1800 he takes back or
leaves to take back Italy.
And when we talk about Italy,
we're really talking about the
Kingdom of Italy, which
was northern Italy.
We're not talking about the
Kingdom of Naples, which was
southern Italy.
Or the Papal States.
Actually let me show you that.
If we go all the
way down here.
You'll see when people talk
about the Kingdom of Italy in
this period of time, they're
really talking about this
region up here, which is
really northern Italy.
The Papal States
are right here.
And you had your Kingdom
of Naples down there.
Compared to modern Europe,
the two countries that we
associate with Europe today that
really didn't exist in a
unified form in the early 1800s
were Italy and Germany.
They were really just broken up
into a bunch of kingdoms.
And as I mentioned before,
Germany at this point, that
confederation of kingdoms was
kind of referred to as the
Holy Roman Empire where the King
of Austria had the title
of Holy Roman Emperor.
But he didn't control the Holy
Roman Empire in a very
centralized fashion.
It was actually controlled by
a bunch of smaller kings.
But anyway, let's go
back to Napoleon.
So that's him crossing
the Alps in 1800.
That ends when he
takes it back.
He defeats Austria.
That is essentially the end
of the Second Coalition.
We learned that in
the last video.
1801.
You had your Treaty
of Luneville.
End of Second Coalition.
They don't have a treaty with
Great Britain until the next
year, really just out
of attrition.
But that doesn't matter, it was
a very short-lived treaty.
And then in 1802, before we
start talking about the Third
Coalition, Napoleon gets
the Constitution
of the Year X passed.
And why do you say year 10?
Remember, they had this whole
revolutionary calendar going.
So in the revolutionary calendar
this was the 10th
year of the Revolution.
But what's really relevant from
Napoleon's point of view
is article one.
It says, the French people name
and the senate proclaims
Napoleon Bonaparte First
Consul for life.
So, if you want to view this
is kind of legally giving
Napoleon almost a king-like
status, it writes it in words
that he will rule France for
the rest of his life.
Then we get to 1803.
And actually, before I get
to 1803, remember what's
happening at the
same time here.
You had your Revolution in
Haiti, which, if you remember
from those videos, Haiti was
the most profitable slave
colony in the world.
Once the slaves revolted, got
their freedom, all of a sudden
not as profitable to France
as it was before.
And remember, the whole French
Revolution started off because
France was broke.
So Napoleon tries to
reinstate slavery.
That essentially backfires
on him.
Dessalines catches wind of
it, him and the other
revolutionaries.
So they essentially
start antagonizing
Leclerc even more.
Leclerc and the French occupiers
get ravaged by
yellow fever.
And Dessalines is a very
aggressive general.
So he starts losing Haiti.
You have Rochambeau, if you
remember from those videos,
he's this hugely brutal figure
who takes over after Leclerc.
But we have this revolution
in Haiti.
And you can kind of say they're
starting to lose Haiti.
And at the same time, and this
is 1802, and as we're entering
into 1803, Napoleon begins to
realize that Great Britain
controls the seas.
Great Britain dominant navy.
And because they're losing
Haiti, which is really their
main profit center, and Great
Britain is dominant, Napoleon
essentially gives up
on North America.
So outside of Haiti, which was
this major profit center for
the French Empire, they also
had the territory of
Louisiana, which is essentially
the middle 1/3 of
what we now consider to
be the United States.
And Napoleon figures out,
gee, Great Britain
has a dominant navy.
I'm giving up on Haiti.
I'm probably going to lose
it anyway to Dessalines.
Let me just give up on
the entire continent.
If I don't sell Louisiana,
either Great Britain or the
United States will probably
be in a good position to
take it from me.
So he decides to
sell Louisiana.
So just as someone, or as an
American, and especially an
American who was born in
Louisiana, it's fascinating
the chain of events that
led up to this.
Because when you learn it from
an American history point of
view, you just say hey Thomas
Jefferson, he was able to get
Louisiana for $15 million.
Why would someone sell,
all of a sudden, this
huge amount of territory?
And the reason is because
Napoleon figured he was going
to lose it no matter what.
Great Britain had this
dominant navy.
And at the same time, he
had nothing else to
protect in the area.
The other major valuable
asset there was Haiti.
So a combination of Great
Britain having this navy and
of the slave revolt in Haiti
ends up within the United
States being able to acquire
what's now the middle 1/3 of
the continent.
You can kind of wonder, if they
never did that, would
they have ever a gone on to
capture the entire west coast?
So these small little
things in history.
And I wouldn't necessarily call
these little things, but
they lead to very tremendous
changes in our modern world.
Anyway, enough about that.
So he sells Louisiana.
Great Britain has
a dominant navy.
At first, Napoleon was amassing
troops up here, he
was thinking about an invasion
of Great Britain.
But more and more it dawns on
him that Great Britain has a
dominant navy.
Great Britain, I think, starts
to feel a little
self-confident.
And they don't like all of the
gains that Napoleon has gotten
in the last two wars.
So, Great Britain declares
war in 1803, in May 1803.
Or I could say United Kingdom of
Great Britain and Ireland,
the same thing.
U.K.
declares war.
And you could view this as the
beginning of the war of the
Third Coalition.
But it's not a coalition yet.
It's just the United Kingdom.
Or it's just Great Britain.
And it really gets
heated in 1805.
Everyone else jumps in.
And now we're talking about
a real coalition.
Now Great Britain is joined
by Austria and Russia.
And Austria, all the time in
every one of these coalitions,
they lose territory to France
and especially Napoleon.
They just want to get revenge.
United Kingdom kind of senses
that they control the water,
they want to get revenge.
Russia doesn't like this
upstart Napoleon.
And so they all jump in.
And so there's two interesting
angles of the War
of the Third Coalition.
Let me write this right here.
This is the Third Coalition.
And there were other people who
jumped in, but these were
the major powers.
So this right here is
the Third Coalition.
So the first thing that happens,
or really the two
almost happen simultaneously.
In October of 1805, the French
navy gets destroyed by the
British in the Battle
of Trafalgar.
This is Trafalgar, it's
actually written here.
And they get destroyed by
Napoleon's good old friend,
Admiral Horatio Nelson.
So this guy was definitely a
thorn in Napoleon's side.
He destroyed Napoleon's ships in
the Battle of the Nile that
stranded their troops
in Egypt.
And now he comes and essentially
destroys the
French navy at the Battle
of Trafalgar.
And this is an image of it.
And I guess the only redeeming
fact of this battle for
Napoleon was that near the end
of the battle, Horatio Nelson
actually gets stricken
by a bullet
and he dies at Trafalgar.
So the Royal Navy, the British
navy was already dominant,
destroying the French navy,
which was the only navy that
could in some way compete
on any level.
Destroying them at Trafalgar
really established British
domination of the seas.
This is actually an image of
the Battle of Trafalgar.
This is the battle
right there.
A bunch of ships just shooting
at each other, you can't
really make out what's
happening.
And just to connect that to
modern day Great Britain, or
the modern day London, this
right here is an image of
Trafalgar Square.
It is named after the Battle
of Trafalgar, which
established Britain is
dominant in the seas.
That is Trafalgar Square
in London.
And if you go there, you will
see Nelson's column.
This is Nelson's column
right there, named
after Horatio Nelson.
And at the very top of it,
there's a little figure, or
it's probably pretty large,
but little relative to the
column, of Horatio
Nelson himself.
So that was a bit of an aside,
but this occurred during the
war of the Third Coalition.
So Napoleon's navy
is destroyed.
But he doesn't give up.
He's just like, OK, oh well, I
can't do much beyond Europe,
but in Europe I can still
do a lot of damage.
So what he does is he
takes his troops.
He had given up on actually
attacking Britain by sea.
He realized that he could never
realistically do that.
Let me show you the troop
movements that were going on
at this time.
So he had troops here that he
had given up on actually
attacking Great Britain.
And what he does is he
meets the Austrians.
So the Austrians are amassing
their troops here.
They actually thought that there
was a possibility that
the main campaign would
go in Italy.
So they actually focused most
of their troops there, that
we'll see as a major mistake.
But they have troops in what is
now southern Germany near
the Black Forest. And then they
also amassed some troops
near Italy.
And then the Russians were
coming up behind.
They weren't able to meet.
And we're dealing with the fall,
this is now September,
October of 1805.
And the Russians were back here
trying to bring their
troops to assist the Austrians
in meeting Napoleon.
And all of these, it's always
unclear on how much of it was
tactical genius versus
pure luck.
Because they didn't have
satellites, they didn't know
where the other troops were.
They didn't necessarily know
exactly what's happening on a
minute-by-minute basis,
like armies do today.
But what happened, and it's one
of the pivotal battles in
European history, is that
Napoleon meets the
Austrians at Ulm.
Let me draw it on this
map right here.
So on this map they just do
a very general-- This is
Napoleon meeting the Austrians
right here at Ulm.
There's actually a
whole campaign of
Ulm, several battles.
But it was a decisive
victory at Ulm.
And the crux of that victory was
that Napoleon was able to
fool the Austrians.
So this is a zoomed-in version
of what was going on here.
This is France.
This is the Black Forest. This
is Austria right there.
Blue is Napoleon troops, red
are the Austrian troops.
And you saw, Austria had amassed
most of their troops
on the Italian front.
So here in Black Forest, you
have your Austrian troops.
What Napoleon did is he had
General Marat make it look
like the main force of the
French were coming straight
from the West. And they did
that by having cavalry
essentially giving the
appearance of a major force
coming in from here.
So the Austrians were thinking,
OK, this is the
direction that we're going to
face our main antagonism from.
But at the same time, the bulk
of the Napoleon's army--
remember he doesn't see exactly
how many people are
here, they just made it
look like this is
the bulk of the army.
But the bulk of the army
actually did what they call a
wheeling manoeuvre, where they
went around the Austrian army.
And they were able to do it much
faster and in a much more
nimble way than anyone
would have predicted.
Because they essentially
didn't have to
carry as many supplies.
They were doing this during
the harvest season.
And this was by design.
If you capture enemy territory
during the harvest season, and
these are things that you
usually don't think about when
you learn about military
battles.
But you've got troops, you've
got to feed the troops.
If they can't capture food from
the land, then you've got
to carry supplies with you.
And supplies are heavy it
slows down your army.
But if you do the attack during
the harvest season, you
don't have to carry food.
You can just take it from the
farmers that you pass by.
They're harvesting food as you
pass by, you just take it, you
can be fast and nimble.
And he essentially went around
the army and was able to
attack the Austrians from
this direction.
And then essentially
destroy them.
And this is why I hinted in the
last video that Napoleon
starts to view himself
as invincible.
And this was before the
Russians could come to
actually reinforce
the Austrians.
So they did it-- by being able
to do it so quickly, they were
able to just only tackle
the Austrians.
So it was a decisive
victory at Ulm.
Let me go to the painting
right there.
This is a painting of the
surrender at Ulm.
And then the combined Russian
and Austrian forces, they
essentially regrouped, but
they re-met Napoleon's
forces after Ulm.
In another several weeks,
at Austerlitz.
And once again, Napoleon
just routed them.
And there's always a debate.
Some of it might have been
tactical genius, some of it
might have been pure luck.
But after routing them at
Austerlitz-- so this is
Austerlitz-- and taking so much
I guess both in terms of
casualties and prisoners from
the enemy without incurring so
much themselves, this really was
the high point in terms of
a battle for Napoleon.
Austerlitz is what really
convinced Napoleon that he is
truly, truly a military
genius.
And that's not saying
that he's not.
But it was such a rout that
he started to imagine that
he's on some level invincible.
And so the outcome, this
essentially ends the war of
the Third Coalition.
And with that ending, Austria
had to give its territory that
it had gotten in Italy.
So Austria had to cede the
territory that it had in
Italy, some of the territory
that it had in Bavaria.
And from, I guess just a general
point of view, this
was historically significant.
Because until this point in
time, this whole area was
called the Holy Roman Empire,
with the King of Austria
calling himself the Holy
Roman Emperor.
Even though he didn't have
direct control over all of
these Germanic regions.
Let me go back up here.
This is in 1805, or we can even
say we're entering 1806,
but in late 1805, with the end
of the Third Coalition, now
the Austrian King no longer
calls himself
the Holy Roman Emperor.
He gives up the title.
And this region right here is
no longer called the Holy
Roman Empire.
It is called the Confederation
of the Rhine.
And it's essentially under the
protection of Napoleon.
And this is the first time--
we're starting to get to a
point, Germany won't
be unified for
another 60 or 70 years.
But we're starting to get to
the point that the German
nation is escaping from
the bounds of being
the Holy Roman Empire.
And so it's getting
in that direction.
So the Holy Roman
Empire is gone.
France gets significant
territory from
Austria, once again.
Russia on some level is just
humbled a little bit.
And then we end in 1806,
or at the end of
1805, with France dominant.
And while all of that was
happening, it was really in
1804 when France was only at
war with Great Britain.
The whole alliance hadn't
formed yet.
It 1804, in December-- and this
is relevant that it's a
peek into his ego.
So this is the year
before Austerlitz.
In 1804, Napoleon declares
himself, or he
crowns himself Emperor.
And this is a picture
of him as Emperor.
And after this point, instead
of being called Napoleon
Bonaparte, he is called
Napoleon I.
And the idea of crowning
yourself Emperor, you might
say, what's the point?
You already were Consul for
life, you have power for your
whole life.
But other than you get this
neat title emperor, which
probably feeds your ego quite
well, but beyond that, this
essentially establishes
a dynasty.
It now says, I'm not
just a First
Consul, I am the emperor.
I'm Napoleon I.
And it implies that his
descendants will continue to
reign over the French Empire.
So on some level, he
kind of destroys
the notion of a republic.
So we're ending the Third
Coalition with France is
dominant in Europe.
It has gotten all of this
territory mainly from Austria.
The Holy Roman Empire
no longer exists.
It's now the Confederation
of the Rhine.
Napoleon, after Austerlitz,
thinks that he is invincible.
And he also is now Emperor.
So all of his visions of
grandeur are coming true.